Now that you've had practice calculating the mean, before we move on, we're
going to go over some properties of the mean. We're going to do this with a
quiz, and this'll be a very challenging question that requires you to think
about what we've discussed and remember how you calculated the mean. If you can
get the answer to this, I'll be super happy. And, if not, don't worry. Again,
this is a very challenging conceptual question. So what are properties of the
mean? Check all that apply. All scores in the distribution affect the mean. The
mean can be described with a formula. Many samples from the same population will
have similar means. The mean of a sample can be used to make inferences about
the population it came from, or the mean will change if we add an extreme value
to the data set.